MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Hello,
big data and BigQuery
developers.
My name is Michael Manoochehri
from the Google
Cloud Platform team.
We have a special show for
you today, a real treat.
Joining me today for the first
time on Google Developers Live
is Felipe Hoffa, our
newest team member.
Felipe Hoffa is joining us on
the Google Cloud Platform
Developer Relations team.
Yesterday, the BigQuery team
launched a set of new features
for BigQuery, and Felipe wrote a
really great blog post about
this on the Google Cloud
Platform and
Google Developers blogs.
And so today, we're going to
take a look at some of these
new features.
We're going to talk about some
use cases that they're really
good for and do some
demonstrations about what you
can do with these features
as well.
So Felipe, do you want to talk
about one of the ones that's
one of my favorite,
my favorite ones?
FELIPE HOFFA: Hello,
everybody.
Welcome to--
this is my first ever GDL video,
so I hope you enjoy it.
And yes, we are bringing today
these new features.
Let's talk about
the first one.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So this is
actually my favorite one.
And I haven't tried out a lot
of these, so I'm going to be
learning about some of these for
the first time from you.
And since you went through all
of these in your blog post for
our blog, you're probably
the person who could
explain this the best.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh yes, yes.
You've been talking to
developers for a long time,
you know what they're doing,
you know how they are doing
BigQuery, but they frequently
have one big request.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yes
FELIPE HOFFA: What's
this request?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Literally
a big request.
Something that we've been asked
for since the beginning
of the BigQuery launch was to
have a result set size that's
large, as large as can be.
Until yesterday, the maximum
result set you could get from
a query was 128 megabytes
of data
compressed, which is a lot.
I mean, that's quite
a lot of data.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
So people were hitting
this limit.
It's a weird limit to hit
because BigQuery's strength is
going from big data
sizes, as Michael
says, as it goes from--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Machine
size data to human data.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
So you have a terabyte
database, you have a
10-terabyte database, and you
need to get knowledge from it.
You want to reduce, to aggregate
this data and to
understand the windows.
Basically, you can always do
that with BigQuery, but
sometimes people needed to get
a big table from a big table,
for example, to transform a
terabyte [? lump ?] table into
another thing, as a column,
transform the data.
They were hitting this limit
of 128 megabytes of
compressed.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And this
actually happens a lot when
you're working with terabyte
size data sets.
Sometimes your result set can
be a gigabyte, and that's
quite a lot of data.
It's hard to use that
instead in,
say, a dashboard situation.
But sometimes, you need to get
that result size back.
And that's normal when your
actual set of data you're
querying is in the
terabyte range.
You'll see that you sometimes do
need just a slice of that,
and that could be a
couple gigabytes.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
So what did we release
yesterday?
We are raising that limit.
There is no limit now.
You can have a result set of
any size with a new flag,
Allow Large Results.
What does this do?
You give it a name for a table,
and it will label the
data in a new table,
or it will append
to an existing one.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So this
is a question I have.
Does that mean it doesn't return
the result set as a
JSON object as a normal
query does?
It actually will just create
a table that you can then
request data from using the
Table Data List Function?
Is that how that works?
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly, yes.
Basically, if you are getting
a result so large, it's not
really convenient to have it in
a JSON file being written
on the network, so it makes
sense to put it on a new table
and to query from it.
It's also pretty convenient if
you have a terabyte table, you
know that BigQuery is charged by
how much data it processes
in each query.
So you might want to separate
this terabyte table into
several gigabyte-sized tables.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
So this is super useful if
you've got something like a
year's worth of data and you
want to cut your data set up
into weeks or months, or
something like that, where you
do need a huge result set, but
you're going to use it later
for other queries.
So that's really useful.
Also, I can't wait to try this
feature because it solves a
problem that I've always had
which is time stamps in
different formats.
So last time we did a BigQuery
launch, we released a native
timestamp format, which
everybody had been asking for.
And until then, we had to put
timestamps as strings or
integer Unix Epoch values, and
that can be pretty annoying
when you want to use the
native time stamp.
So now what we can do is we take
our terabytes of data, we
can run a query that says,
cast this to a different
timestamp, and then just export
that as this new table,
which is great.
I think this is going
to be super useful.
Developers, I think, are going
to love this a lot.
And we'd love to hear how you
like it, if you have any
problems using this flag.
I want to say one thing.
Why do we have this option?
Why do you have to choose
the option of the flag?
And I think it's because when
you're making these tables,
they can be really big, and we
want to make sure you know
that you're generating these
large tables because storage
does cost you something
in BigQuery.
We want to make sure you know
you're doing it, so that's why
we have this flag.
FELIPE HOFFA: And when you're
using this flag, you are
losing one feature.
You can't order by the
entire result set.
Basically, sorting a terabyte
data table for only one result
is a big task, so that's
disabled, but you can do that
on your smaller result set.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: OK, so you
can actually run a query,
make this big table.
You can't order it in that
table, but then you can run a
query later to do an Order
By or something.
That sounds pretty good.
I think a lot of our developers
are really
going to like that.
It's been one of our most
requested features.
And so the BigQuery team, they
take a lot of pride into
listening to what developers
want and actually releasing
the features that are
most requested.
So I think another one that's
been requested for quite a
while is one that you talked
about yesterday, which I need
to learn more about.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
I think you're talking about
the Window Functions.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yes,
What are Window Functions?
FELIPE HOFFA: Well, Window
Functions are giving you the
ability to analyze your
data in smarter ways.
You're dealing with
a lot of data.
Your are sorting it, you are
ordering it, but sometimes you
want to get a row number.
BigQuery wasn't giving you a
row number for its result.
That was pretty easy to run
before because you get your
results, you can get a row
number on the application
side, but sometimes you
want to use that
number for further queries.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
So the Window Function, the way
I understand it is you can
run a query and get a result.
And then once you get that
result, this batch of data, a
Window Function is something
that you run on top of that.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So you get
this result, and then you
do something else with
that result.
One of them is adding
row numbers.
So this is something you do
after the result has been run.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: OK, so
row numbers, that's cool.
A lot of people have been
asking us for that.
So what are some other examples
of things you do
after the query?
FELIPE HOFFA: Well, row number
has many variations.
You can turn it into a
rank where you are
ordering your data.
The rank, there are
at least two ways
to solve equal values.
When there are ties, you can
say they are in a different
rank just because one comes
after the other by chance.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So a lot
of our developers are game
developers, they love to
put game analytics.
And so this is awesome because
you can actually take this
whole set of data and you can
find out things like-- well,
first of all, row numbers
are useful, like
what's the first place.
But if you want to do a ranking,
you could say, of all
the things in my database, what
are the first, second,
and you said, if there's a tie
in the ranking, what happens?
FELIPE HOFFA: You can solve
it in many ways.
You can rank your players one,
two, three, four in an
arbitrary order, if they
have the equal score.
Or you can give the same
rank for people that
have the same score.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
OK, this is awesome.
Do you think we could show
a quick demo of how these
functions work?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
I guess you have seen what we
did for I/O. We put out 500
sensors all around Moscone.
We got a lot of readings--
temperature, humidity, noise.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: If you're
interested in this project, by
the way, we called it the
Data Sensing Lab.
We worked with the O'Reilly
Data Sensing Lab Team.
And our teammate, Kim Cameron
up in Seattle did a great
Google I/O video, which is
available on YouTube.
You can go check it out.
It's called "Behind the Data
Sensing Lab." And Amy Unruh
from the AppEngine Team was
also involved with that.
So the data we collected from
that, we have it in
BigQuery right now.
We're going to actually release
it for everybody to
use as soon as we can.
But the example you're going to
do is based on this data?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
Let's take this data.
You will have it available to
run your own experiments, but
let me run some experiments
now with it.
Can we switch to the computer?
I have here my table from
Moscone I/O '13.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So this
is the schema of the data.
So you've got a timestamp.
Actually, we have multiple
timestamps.
I remember that we had different
places where the
data was being sent, and at
every location, we'd have a
different timestamp.
So the sensor had its own.
The AppEngine app we were
collecting the data in has its
own timestamp because it took
a little bit of time.
So we have multiple
timestamps.
What else is in here?
FELIPE HOFFA: The data is
a very important one.
That's where we get the data.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
The data itself.
FELIPE HOFFA: And we got
the sensor type.
So how we measure, does this
row have a temperature?
Does it have a noise reading,
an air quality reading?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So each
sensor that we placed around
Moscone was measuring
different things.
It was like the temperature
and the pressure
and things like that.
These are the kind of functions
that you see a lot
in relational databases often
when the data can be small.
But what's great about BigQuery
is now you can run
these kind of queries over
really large data
sets, easily via API.
These are like terabyte
data sets.
This is fantastic.
FELIPE HOFFA: We will
talk about this.
This query ran a very fast
because it's [? Cat. ?]
I'll tell you more
about that later.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
I heard about this.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
So we have the median, and you
can see that we got three
million data points.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
So quite a lot.
FELIPE HOFFA: Quite a lot.
And each one, let's go to
the last, for example.
In the [? Wallet ?]
Room, the median was 29, but we
have many values for this
median because it's going
through the window.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Like
every data point, right?
FELIPE HOFFA: Every data point
is getting the median for that
room, so we really want
to group this data.
We can do that very easily
with this query.
Let me run it, and I will tell
you more about this.
So we are running the same
query, and now I'm
grouping the data.
Max median is the same as
minimum median because--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It's
just the median.
FELIPE HOFFA: [INAUDIBLE] median
is the same for each
room, and I'm grouping
by room.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: OK,
so this is cool.
So you're showing me the median
temperature over all
the data that we collected,
which is a lot of
data, and by room.
So in this case, we're calling
the hallway a room and the
lounge is a room.
This is great.
FELIPE HOFFA: So we have 72
rooms in Moscone, and each one
has its median temperature.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: I saw
the word "blimp" there.
I remember we put some of the
sensors in the blimps that
were floating around,
which was very fun.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh, yes.
This was a very cool thing.
We had three sensors there.
So now, that's last time, and
now I'm doing a [INAUDIBLE]
rank over it.
I'm ordering it by million
in ascending order.
So first, I get the coldest
rooms in I/O.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Looks like
the coldest room was the
entrance, which makes
a lot of sense.
FELIPE HOFFA: Oh, yes.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
OK, great.
So this is wonderful.
So for the sake of time, we have
a lot of other things to
cover, but what are some of
the other Window Functions
that are available?
There was one with ratio.
Can you explain that
ratio one?
FELIPE HOFFA: Ratio to Report.
That one is great.
With that, we could see how much
of a contribution each
data point makes.
I was running some queries
yesterday that I wanted to
know the ratio of men to women,
so I was able to count
them, as you have always
been able to count.
Then when I counted, I was
asking the ratio to report.
What does this number
represent as a
percentage of the total?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: OK.
So I remember you explaining
this to me yesterday.
So one thing I thought was a
great use case is if you're
doing sales, or something
related to that, or even if
you have more data log files.
So what Ratio to Report does,
correct me if I'm wrong, is
sum up everything in a column.
And then whatever field you have
that you're comparing it
to, it's that contribution
to the sum.
So you could do things like,
what contribution does this
particular salesperson have to
the total amount of sales?
Or what contribution does this
player have to the total
amount of games being played?
Things like that, which is
really amazing, especially if
you have these really
large data sets.
You can get these things in a
single query without having to
do extra joins, things
like that.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
Previously, you could do that
with an extra join.
There were smart ways
to solve it.
But now, it's smarter.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Incredibly fast.
How did you do that?
FELIPE HOFFA: [INAUDIBLE].
I already computed once.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yes.
FELIPE HOFFA: That's what
BigQuery can do now.
It can remember.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So you
remembered the original query
result and you just told me
immediately without having to
run the whole thing over.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And so
BigQuery does this now, too?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
BigQuery is getting smarter
and faster.
If you ask the same question
and it has the same answer,
BigQuery will say that answer.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So
it caches the answer.
This is very smart.
It caches the answer.
So now, instead of waiting seven
seconds for your query,
you get it immediately.
So caching is hard.
Let me ask you a few questions
about caching, because I'm
trying to understand
how this works.
Caching works when the table
might not change.
What if I add data
to the table?
Then what happens
to the cache?
FELIPE HOFFA: Well, in that
case, the cache goes away.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: The
cache goes away.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yeah.
BigQuery is smart about this.
It realizes the table is not the
same, so it will just dump
the previous results and let
you get new results.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
And in your blog post,
you talked about
deterministic queries.
So one example of this is if I
have a query that depends on a
current timestamp, I'm not
actually putting the timestamp
but I'm asking BigQuery to tell
me, then every time I
make that query, the
time stamp changes.
So does that get cached, too?
FELIPE HOFFA: No, that
doesn't get cut.
If you want your data to
be cut, you have to use
deterministic queries.
What is a deterministic query?
A query where its meaning
doesn't change with time.
For example, if I use a Now
function, Now changes every
time I query.
So current time won't be
the same, the query
doesn't get to be cached.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: OK,
so that's great.
So if the table doesn't change
and your query itself
literally doesn't change and
does not depend on some of
these functions like Now,
then it will be cached.
FELIPE HOFFA: The limit
of queries per day.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: OK.
So the query quota limit
doesn't change, but the
queries do return faster.
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
And you don't get charged
for them.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And you'll
get charged for them.
OK, that's excellent.
I think people are going
to like that a lot.
OK, so we have a bunch
of other things.
Let's just zip through
the rest.
I'll just say one more thing.
This particular function and
the large query results are
now available in the API, and
you can read about that on our
documentation site, and the
BigQuery command line tool.
And I believe all of
these are also
available in the UI itself.
So you can actually say, large
results in the UI, cache the
query in the UI, things
like that.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
We have two ways to access
BigQuery now.
We have the BQ tool, we have the
web UI, we have the API.
They both allow this option.
Also, you might want not to have
a cache for some queries,
just to run interactive demos.
In that case, you can go in the
web UI to Enable Options.
You are able to set them
on or off as you want.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
OK, excellent.
So speaking of dashboards, let's
just touch on some of
the other things we launched.
One was an increase in the quota
for querying, right?
So before yesterday, the maximum
amount of querying you
could do is 200 gigabytes
at a time.
So all your querying processing
had to add up to
200 gigabytes, plus we
gave you one extra
query of any size.
That's so you could do these
massive queries.
So now, we've actually
increased that.
And can you remind me what
the increase was?
FELIPE HOFFA: Yes.
We are doubling the quota.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: We're
doubling it, OK.
FELIPE HOFFA: We are doubling
the 200 gigabytes and we are
doubling the limited queries
from one to two at a time.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So Felipe
and I were just talking about
accessibility, and I think the
whole point of BigQuery is to
make these large data processing
tasks more
accessible via API for
developers, and this pricing
changes, the query caching, and
the quota updates are just
meant to increase the
accessibility.
So we're really excited, and
I think it's going to help
developers a lot
with learning.
FELIPE HOFFA: And
about pricing.
Are you a high volume user?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Oh,
I definitely am.
I use BigQuery tons,
all day long.
FELIPE HOFFA: Exactly.
If you are a high volume user,
there is also good news for
you because you are able to
obtain tiered pricing where
you have further discounts.
So more good news to use
more of BigQuery.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah,
we can't wait.
I guess the other thing we've
done, is I mentioned before,
we've added some UI updates.
We've updated our client
libraries, we've updated our
BigQ command line tool, and
we've also updated our
documentation.
So please, just go check out
our documentation at
developers.google.com/bigquery.
And if you have questions,
there's a lot of places you
could reach us.
You should definitely
follow the Google
Cloud Platform G+ page.
There's also the Google
Developers+ page.
Again, reach out to us
on Stack Overflow at
Google-BigQuery.
And you can follow Felipe and
I. We're on Google+ as well.
Just look for us there.
And we're happy to
hear from you.
We want to see what you guys are
building, and I hope that
you use some of these new
features to build some cool
applications and share
them with us.
So thanks for joining us.
My name is Michael
Manoochehri.
FELIPE HOFFA: And I'm
Felipe Hoffa.
Thank you for joining us today.